hi guys today I've come across another
kind of random indie game for you it's
called sin and this is just a demo so
the game isn't complete yet but you can
find it on Steam to play for absolutely
free i'll leave the link in the
description basically is a game for you
to explore how it feels to be in the
mind of someone who suffers with social
anxiety i love all these kind of games
that try to break the boundaries of what
games normally do I think it's pretty
cool that you can play explore and
create so it looks like you can kind of
make your own levels and stuff I love me
get my own levels everyone else young
guys play Eggbert and the best part of
egbert was just making your own levels
but anyway I'm just gonna play the
normal game oh it's like a little alien
those tentacles I'll be quite serious
serious topic
aatrox games mastertronic and all those
who contributed present okay I was
pretty cool down the rabbit hole it's
like Alice in Wonderland do this okay
age your left oh right yes i can use run
how do we run how am I already running
here I feel safe trapped inside fall
fall fall I wonder I can't read this is
too fast jump with that yeah a little
effort little if it goes a long way he
looks like like a cuter version of
slender man really without the suit eyes
watching me always hide myself with s or
down to a safe cocoon I look at me I
wouldn't like a weird little cocoon
state so hmm that's interesting oh ok
awesome
pressing the button and jumping or
moving out can change things according
to the near symbols pressing the button
of this button oh ok shiza what'd I do
wrong can I do this oh yes I like my own
little world here I'm the ruler don't
know we although i love my own little
world so much more simple wait this I
want to be I want to jump and when I go
into the phone ok
I already done nothing can hurt me I
don't know what I'm doing okay stay away
from the eyes welcome to the garden evil
plans are waiting for you what's the
ground seeds are dangerous oh schizer
yeah they really are dangerous I didn't
even know that was a seed okay good ah
plants can can't see you if you stay in
into dark world okay let's get to know
wha oh yeah
what
are you still alive good that's why I am
I'm good at this oh I'm never saying
that again no over here it's fine but
the funds aren't doing anything to me is
there looking at me they're just looking
at me but I guess is that that's the
whole point the social anxieties you
just don't like people love you okay
whoo well um when you get to the age
where you start thinking about careers
and people a lot of high expectations da
it's easy to just want to kind of be on
your own keep calm and press the button
okay now what
okay clap you did it well done well done
however I'm faster blades are deadly
only in the dark world left whoo people
are looking at me so each words world
has got its dangers maybe I can look
this way into the deep run for your life
okay oh shiz it what do I do now woohoo
okay Elle's all right don't feed the
animals what are they they're animals
okay whatever you say okay ha
Oh didn't see that whoops okay I'm gonna
ask you this way ah made it I like
animals but they don't like me oh so
people with social anxiety and trouble
with animals as well oh that sucks oh
that sucks what do i do I side is this
good oh my god Oh Duke dirt
right the eyes are hurting me the
pinpricks up crap I want to get to that
door maybe a good this way
this is a button
I want to go home now so do i so do I
finally the trip is over but you're
standing on I walls I'm scared that was
difficult where am I am I like how it
sounds like you're underwater when
you're in your little cocoon mode Oh
balls did see that whoo does he do a
little some sort yeah cute why why why
why they follow me he's no one's
following you are you talking about why
oh jeez is it if this is like the first
eration that people feel with really bad
social
I guess it's over them shiza this is bad
okay it's okay I'm just gonna have to
miss these little animals do not feed
the animals so I almost don't like me so
I'll wait wait for them to all walk past
yoyo kakakakaka do run run run run yes
okay whoa
you
you
oh dude concentration mode this way
wonder if this was just designed by
drawings it looks like it was I like it
how am I gonna do this can I jump on him
like Mario that's hope so Oh bowls you
can okay
yes yeah why do the TV so alone okay he
is leave me alone but they just want to
be your friend shut up don't look oh but
that was stupid yeah oh that was very
stupid as well hit again my what's
happening y'all know yeah it's dangerous
yeah we already know that we've died
like 20 bazillion times it's going to
wait for that little platforms come
round what are you gonna do you any gay
oh my gosh that's what do you know okay
this butter there's a trick
what is the trick what is the trick oh
the door yes thanks for playing please
buy the full game hide so is that the
trick hiding help us help us Josh needs
you who's Josh wait I'm not reading this
ah I need to go back what does it say Oh
loneliness I think Oh Josh lonely no I
want to read it so thanks for playing in
all that jazz and then it says that Josh
needs us you must help josh and josh is
lonely i'm jumping like a maniac that's
the end I think yeah that was quite an
interesting game I'm not the best
platformers and so if that was anointed
watch but I do get where they're coming
from they're trying to make you feel on
edge and anxious or at least that's what
I get from the game I guess everyone
will probably get something slightly
different but it's a cool insight into
what people might be feeling with social
anxiety obviously everyone with social
anxiety probably feels slightly
different dealing with things you're
being out in public and how difficult
that can be for people with social
anxiety and always wanting to stay
cocooned in their little bubble and stay
away from prying eyes so I'm looking
forward to seeing the full game and how
they develop it and maybe how they put
some more narrative in it is josh going
to be a part of the game they're making
a game about a guy called josh who has
social anxiety and he wants to explain
it give this a thumbs up if you enjoyed
it up at the link in the description
below so you can have
yourselves and have a video evening by
it's a cat so sweet and pretty dark is
the deepest night I run a kitty it's mr.
midnight
haha so cute my best friend
my only friend